welcome everyone this screencast is an
overview of assignment one and the
associated Bake Off the goal here is to
give you a sense for the nature of the
work that is the nature of the questions
that you'll be answering as well as the
thinking behind them and I think that
will help you both with the current work
and also with subsequent assignments
because they all follow similar rhythms
and have a kind of similar philosophy
behind them
for this assignment Bake Off pairing
we're going to be doing multi-domain
sentiment analysis for the work we're
going to be in Jupiter notebooks we're
going to be fitting classifiers with
scikit-learn as well as fine tuning
parameters that we load in with hugging
face code
if that's new to you or if you need a
refresher I would encourage you to check
out the materials that are linked from
this page of the course site we have a
lot of stuff there for you including
basic tools kind of deep background
stuff on scientific Computing in Python
and pytorch working in Jupiter notebooks
and this final notebook here will really
help you work productively in the
context of our course code base which
offers lots of starter code that can
help you fit powerful models with
relatively little coding yourself
and then specifically for supervised
learning we have a lot of materials
again some deep background stuff on
supervised learning in general and then
a lot of materials that are actually
oriented toward sentiment analysis we've
got videos and slideshows as well as
notebooks that will help you get
Hands-On with the material
so again if this is new to you or if you
need a refresher I would encourage you
to check out this these materials and
they will get you to the point where you
can work productively on this first
assignment and Bake Off
task setting as I said is multi-domain
sentiment analysis we're going to pose
this as a ternary problem so we'll have
labels positive negative and neutral
for training and development we're going
to offer you three major resources
dynasent round one is a large data set
of naturally occurring sentences that
were labeled with ternary sentiment by
crowd workers
dinescent round two is a somewhat
smaller data set that consists of
examples that were written from scratch
by crowd workers in an effort to fool a
top performing sentiment model and again
they were validated separately by crowd
workers and then the Stanford sentiment
Tree Bank is a classic sentiment data
set it's released in a five label format
and we have reformatted it slightly to
conform to the ternary sentiment
specification
so those are resources that you have
available to you for training and
development all of this is oriented
around entering our bake off and for the
Bake Off test set you're going to have
examples drawn from the test sets from
those above resources as well as a set
of mystery examples whose Origins is are
unknown to you and the idea here is that
we're going to pose a hard sentiment
task to give you a real sense for how
your system generalizes even to examples
that are unlike the ones that you could
anticipate when you're doing training
and other kinds of development
in that spirit I want to make an
important methodological note
the dynasent and SSD test sets are
public that means you have the labels
for all of those examples we are
counting on people not to cheat in the
Bake Off by developing their models on
those test sets evaluate exactly once on
the test set and turn in the results
with no further system tuning or
additional runs it is a sin in our field
to do any kind of model selection based
on performance on the test set the idea
is that you run your system once on the
test set and submit the results much of
the scientific Integrity of our field
depends on people adhering to this Honor
Code the function of a test set is to
give us a true glimpse of how your
system performs on examples that were
unseen during system development so you
have to keep that test set under lock
and key until the very end we can
guarantee that for our mystery examples
but not for the examples that are drawn
from these public test sets we need to
rely on this honor code
all right that's the background stuff
we're gonna what we're going to start
doing now is kind of walking through the
notebook itself we're going to start
with data loading we're going to use
load data set from hugging face to load
in the dynasent rounds as well as the
SST and as I said before the SSD gets
loaded in a five label format and the
notebook does the work of reformatting
it into the ternary problem
we also have a little function called
print label distribution and it will
show you the distribution of labels for
one of these splits here's the
distribution for dynascent route one
that's a large resource dynascent round
two is somewhat smaller and the SST is
the smallest of these resources
now we come to the assignment work
itself beginning with question one
linear classifiers what we're going to
be doing here is developing relatively
lightweight models that depend on
typically very sparse feature
representations you could think of these
as kind of being bag of words models
that you might augment to make them more
interesting
here's how the outline looks
we've got four background sections and
then three subtasks I urge you to work
through the background sections first
before you begin the tasks whether you
need a refresher or whether this is
really what you do every day I think the
background sections will pay off in
terms of helping you get hands on with
the code and also just for a refresher
on the Core Concepts so work through
them and then dive into the tasks
question one task one is about writing
feature functions and for the background
section we wrote one for you this is
unigrams Phi it takes in a string splits
that string on white space and
essentially just counts the resulting
unigrams it returns a dictionary mapping
unigrams to their counts in the input
string that is the basis for
featurization in the context of
scikit-learn as we'll be using it so
that's our example and then the task
here is simply to write a better version
of that we've called that tweetgrams Phi
and the core of this is just using this
really nice tokenizer from nltk which
does a good job with things like
emoticons and other kinds of punctuation
and so forth it will be a superior basis
for feature functions this is a very
simple coding task the idea here is to
get your creative juices flowing have
having written this feature function you
might think about new ways of tokenizing
or new things you could do in terms of
feature organization to build ever more
powerful models
so this is just the start
I want to say something about unit tests
you will notice in this homework that
every single one of the questions has an
Associated unit test and that is true
for every question on all the
assignments for the course
so make sure that you use those unit
tests I'm not going to belabor this
throughout the screencast and the
subsequent ones but those unit tests are
always there they perform a crucial role
it is very hard for us to fully
disambiguate what we're looking for in
terms of coding in English
so instead we rely on these unit tests
if you pass the unit test then you have
completed the task as we defined it you
will also get a clean bill of health
from the auto grader when you submit and
everything should go swimmingly
so make use of these unit tests they
also help you with Core Concepts and
other aspects of the problem they'll
give you feedback if the unit tests fail
and in general help you iterate toward a
successful outcome
so use those unit tests
for question one task two this is model
training what you should do first is
work through the two Associated
background sections on feature space
vectorization and on scikit learn models
and then you're well set up to tackle
this particular task
the task is relatively straightforward
you need to complete a function called
train linear model you can see here
we've given you a detailed doc string
and then in comments we've walked you
through the steps that you need to take
to complete the function this is not
meant to be difficult conceptually or in
terms of coding if you did that
background reading and you're up to
speed on the Core Concepts this will be
very straightforward the idea here is to
give you an asset a function that you
can use for very efficiently training
new linear models in case you decide to
train a lot of these models as part of
developing an original system
so straightforward coding you complete
that and then you have this new asset to
work with
question one task 3 is very similar this
is model assessment work through the
background section and then you should
be well set up for the the question
itself again the core task is to
complete a simple function this one is
called assess linear model we've
provided documentation and we've walked
you through the steps that you need to
take it should be straightforward
because again the idea here is to give
you another tool that you can use for
very efficiently assessing models that
you've trained so that you can iterate
toward really interesting models if you
decide to
that's it for question one we now come
to question two we're gonna switch gears
a little bit we're gonna start working
with hugging face code and we're going
to be fine tuning pre-trained models in
this case in this case a Bert Mini model
here's the outline again you have some
background sections work through them
first and then you'll be set up to do
the three subtasks associated with this
question
let's look at question two task one this
is a another tokenization question batch
tokenization you'll be using hugging
face code so work through the background
material and then dive into the question
you just need to complete a function get
batch token IDs the spirit of this is to
get you thinking about how hugging face
tokenizers work make you aware of the
various keyword arguments that they have
and in general get you thinking about
how to use these functions effectively
in the context of fine tuning models
so again not a hard coding task you
should just follow the instructions and
kind of look around at the hugging face
documentation in order to do this work
question two task two is about
representation again this is about
getting used to the way hugging face
code works and about the way models like
Bert represent examples so you work
through the background section and then
you can tackle the associated task which
involves completing a function get reps
and again we've walked you through the
steps because the idea here it is to
give you a sense very quickly for what
the representations are like and how you
might use them
and then the final question is similar
this is the most involved though because
this is where the pieces kind of come
together question two task three is
writing a fine tuning module
so there's one more background section
on masking that you should check out and
then you'll be well set up to do this
you're going to be completing an NN
module that we call Bert classifier
module there are two parts to that you
complete the init method and that helps
you set up the core computation graph
and you can see here we've provided a
lot of guidance in terms of
documentation and other description and
then you also complete the forward
method which is core for How We Do
inference in this model and makes use of
the graph that you set up in the init
method
and then you're all set it's just a few
lines of code it is not meant to be
complicated again the idea is that once
you have a functioning bird classifier
module you have something that you could
easily modify to do more powerful and
creative things for the original system
one more note we have a section called
classifier interface marked as optional
use
you don't have to train any models as
part of the core questions for this
assignment but you might want to train
some original models as part of
evaluating original systems our
classifier interface can help out of the
box it will allow you to work with the
NN module that you just wrote to
actually train on data and do
assessments so it's there for you as a
kind of wrapper and it's straightforward
also as you iterate on your NN module to
continue to make use of this classifier
interface and if you'd like a deeper
dive on those Concepts check out this
this tutorial notebook which I mentioned
at the start of the screencast
and now we come to the heart of it in my
view the most exciting part question
three original systems you can do pretty
much whatever you want the task is to
develop an original ternary sentiment
classifier model there are many options
for this we have really only one rule
you cannot make any use of the test sets
for dynasent round one dynasant round
two or the SST at any time during the
course of developing your original
system it is under lock and key
another note this needs to be an
original system so it doesn't suffice to
just download code from the web retrain
it and submit you can build on people's
code but you have to figure out how to
do something new and meaningful with it
we will be evaluating your work based on
the extent to which you try original
creative things not on the underlying
performance of the systems this is not
so much about being at the top of the
leaderboard although I grant that that's
exciting it is more about creative
Exploration with code and with data and
with modeling techniques
you feel uncertain about this question
of originality I would encourage you to
interact with the course team they'll
give you guidance about whether
something is original enough and maybe
suggests new avenues if they feel that
you should be doing more
One technical note about this you'll
notice that in this notebook and in all
the assignment notebooks there's the
original system cell
please follow these instructions this
really amounts to adding a description
of your system and the code for the
system between the start comment and
stop comment lines here and do not
disrupt those two lines they are crucial
we want you to do this for a few reasons
first technically your code has to be
between these two comments so the auto
grader knows to ignore it if you put
your original code elsewhere in the
notebook it might really cause the grade
scope Auto grader to fail because it
doesn't know how to execute your code it
doesn't have libraries you need and so
forth in addition we really value these
textual descriptions and the
descriptions are especially important if
you've tried a bunch of different things
and decided to reject those options in
favor of maybe a simple looking original
system you want to get credit for all
that exploratory work that you did and
you can get that only if you describe
the work to us so take advantage of the
textual description of the system to
kind of get full credit for all of your
efforts
having developed the original system
you're going to enter it into the bake
off and this really amounts to grabbing
some new unlabeled examples and running
your system on those examples in a bit
more detail you can see here that you
load in the unlabeled examples and then
the task is to add a new column called
prediction make sure it's called
prediction and make sure it consists of
strings positive negative or neutral
those are your predictions
once you've done that you write that to
disk as a file with this name and then
you upload it to grade scope and we'll
have a leaderboard that kind of shows
you how people did
make sure when you submit to grade scope
that you submit files with these two
names it's really important that you
keep those names the autograder is
looking for files with these names and
if it fails to find them it will report
that you didn't get any credit so make
sure you use those file names and then
you should be all set
this is really exciting stuff you've
developed an original system you run it
on these unlabeled examples when
everyone has submitted all of their
systems we'll reveal everyone's scores
and then the teaching team will do a
report reflecting back to all of you
what people did what worked and what
didn't and that is often the most
exciting part of this intellectually
because you get this wonderful look at
all the creative and original things
people tried some of them were blazing
successes some of them failed miserably
all of that is incredibly instructive
about how to do problems like this one
even better and so that's the most
exciting and informative part of this
whole experience for me so go forth try
creative ambitious things and we will
all learn from the results